richard is with us in Boston hey Richard
how are you good how are you did better
than I deserve what's up I'm just
wondering my my parents they're
fortunate enough to have a great deal of
money and no debt and they would like to
buy me a car mm-hmm
but I have $15,000 my own savings and
I'm wondering is it the adult thing to
do for me to purchase the car on my own
or to pay for half or to do something
like that mm-hmm
are you adult and mature with the rest
of your money
well I'm 19 years old so this is just
summer money and I'm not really living
on my own or anything I'm just a college
student okay
all right and they're gonna buy you a
nice car and they're wealthy people yes
and there's no strings attached there's
no debt involved nope they purchased one
for my sister and they say we want to be
fair we'll do one for you too mm-hmm and
it'll be in your name I believe it will
be in their name just for the insurance
to keep it a little bit cheaper mm-hmm
until what I think with my sister when
she turned 25 they said you're on your
own now mm-hmm and how wealthy are your
parents how many what's their net worth
probably you know uh I'd say they easily
make $200,000 a year helpful income and
are they worth several million dollars
and net worth I'd say at least at least
two okay all right and how expensive a
car are they buying you they bought my
sister I think it was $22,000 out the
door mm-hmm okay that would probably be
the same for me yeah no I don't think
that's going to damage your character I
think you're gonna be fine
because of the way you've asked this
question and because of the conversation
we've had around the question it
indicates that you know you're a you're
concerned about it B you know you want
to be a grown-up and on your own that
kind of thing I will give you a piece of
advice because I did the same thing with
my kids as they hit that age I put the
car in their name because if the cars in
your parents name and you have a wreck
they can be sued and they have money you
don't so I would pay the extra insurance
and put the car in your name as risk
management for them
that way they're not don't have a target
on there but if you happen to have a car
accident and I did that with mine so
just an idea this is the Dave Ramsey
show